So let's continue to look at aperture.
Here I've just schematically shown you f/2.8 to f/16, larger
aperture opening, smaller number, smaller aperture opening, larger number.
So the f number here is 16, the f number here is 2.8.
more, the larger the opening, more the light will enter the sensor,
smaller the opening, less the light will enter the sensor,
assuming we keep the fixed same amount of shutter time, of the shutter speed.
So, just by looking at it, we should be able to discern that, if I double the N,
it would reduce the area by 2 times, and therefore,
it would reduce the light by 4 times.
So let's look at a specific example.
We will look at f/2.8 and f/5.6, where the end number has doubled.
So going from f/2.8 to f/5.6 will cut the light by four times.
And you can actually look at the math and
figure this one out on your own as to why that's happening.
Partly it has something to do with the fact that you have a square of
this value that's going to impact the size of the area.
If you want to cut the light by two times,
basically what you need to do is increase the N by the square root of 2.
So that basically starts kind of giving us a sense as to why these
numbers are there.
And again, you can do the same math between f/4 and f/8, or
f/8 and f/16, to be able to get a four times reduction of light.